allez l'heure d'accueillir louer dix
parties de musique est avec nous depuis
hier qui a eu un succès des messages
toute la soirée qu'est ce que c'était
marrant patrick chan frais après le jt
sera prêt mais arrêtez vous avez un
succès fou et plein de meuf qui m'ont
écrit on est qui est ce garçon cherche à
cerner ce chicano commence tout de suite
alors on va tester votre petite culture
de la télé attention si je vous dis
secretstory 3 castaldi miss france 2007
rapporte le drap rencontre lâchait le
graet radio rachel legrain trapani qui
devait se faire passer pour rosa une
candidate lambda sauf qu'elle s'est fait
démasquer en trois secondes 40 alors là
vous avez diaries donc cocotte un peu
sur deux là que tu frêche
ah ouais mais vous regardez tout
comprendre juste après pourquoi je vous
parle de cette image
bon ça alors je vous rappelle que je
vous rappelle que que grey's anatomy que
rachel miss france 2007 et qu'elle doit
dissimuler aux autres évidemment sa
célérité son titre c'est que pour le fun
et pour la blague et on l'instant
personne ne l'a reconnu en même temps
ouais ouais alors connais un peu cette
venelle est miss france
voilà donc ouais et donc jusqu'ici
c'était le canular le plus court de
l'histoire des canulars mais hier le
record a été battu sur ce champion du
monde du caviar à gérard depardieu
bravo mais il géra bravo regarder
on va appeler yann moix on va essayer de
le piéger tu veux dire que tu es en
galère parce que tu t'es fait choper par
ton voisin parce que tu a défoncé sa
voiture avec son scooter allez c'est
parti on n'a pas les yann moix
on est en direct bien sûr dès cette
année c'est fou même le téléphone allô
allô oui morjan oui bonjour convaincu
ben ça va je suis avec eux cyril
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on voit ce genre de parc a été ravie
d'être avec vous merci
alors avec ça c'est ça qu'on fasse
tourner mais cette fois nous leur faire
tu va nous remettre sexuelle et 7
secondes seulement
c'est génial attention maintenant je
vais avoir besoin de vous oui se
concentre au niveai attention atchik
atchik atchik ok c'est bon sens qu'on a
été dans le même mariage passait dans 4
mariages pour une lune de miel et les
mariés avaient un petit grain de voix
âge est à deux doigts d inscrire à ce
vol
[Applaudissements]
m
des maillots
[Applaudissements]
desgagnés
je sais pas pour vous mais moi on dirait
ma famille et ils sont tous persuadés
qu'ils chantent ou permet un problème et
c'est pareil six mois roger pailles qui
pour le meilleur chanteur de la table
c'est appréciable chanter bien où ça
j'ai entendu c'est sûr que s'ils
allaient la nouvelle brique et qui
chante comme un délit
alors qu'elle est liée à weekend a nommé
priscilla on va alors si c'est kelly ça
vous montre un petit peu le niveau local
de l'équipe à voilà merci merci vous
évidemment je mords de rien mdr allez
c'est parti
une enquête exclusive on a retrouvé le
mec qui avait le moins de chance au
monde
retenez bien son nom il s'appelle guy et
guy et ben c'est un groupe poissard
crépitements ce sont les bleus qui
s'écrase surtout le cône à quelques
mètres du groupe
mais guy n'est toujours pas inquiet
franchement ça c'est vraiment pas de
chance qu'un blog qui parle de cratères
qui arrive izik en vain
justement et pourtant quelques secondes
plus tard
grosse éruption bombardent tout autour
du cône bagarre
une pluie d'obus s'abat sur le groupe
ray monfroy
il va bien j'avais très bien il va bien
guy va bien heureusement bien sûr s'ils
ne les aurais pas montré les images mais
c'est vrai que la ville a du pif avait
dit la même chose moi j'avais dit il ya
11 ans j'avais à dire je serais vraiment
poissard si jean michel maire fait des
missions avec moi tous les jours et
maintenant je suis plus heureux du monde
ayad il ya des messages sur vous tous
magnifiques ne pas exagérer non ça va
pas le premier message apparaît le
footballeur djibril cissé était l'invité
de cyril lignac dans l'émission tous en
cuisine
alors on s'est rendu compte que djibrine
était aussi rapide pour marquer les buts
que pour pété un câble il faut dire que
niveau collection téléphonique on est
sûr de la 3g roumaine du coup en cuisine
c'était plutôt crowcon que gourmands
c'est un honneur de talent dans ma
cuisine mon pote graz et aaron cm il est
à toi alors à temps et ce qui en reste
il reste les gares et pour demain et
cela les vosges et hautmont et bien
allez on est bien alors non je n'ai pas
dont continue simonet des pâtes on
écoute écoute les bras tant aimée dans
quoi encore dans le cas où le cdh à
l'écran du cochon coach dahlgren chara
l'air on les met des dons ou là où tu es
n'ont pas dit bill
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voyez ça typiquement mine de rien
j'adore cyril in ils sont en train m6
qui aime beaucoup ils sont en train de
l'envoyer dans le mur
avec cette émission qui perd tous les
jours des téléspectateurs c'était une
émission qui a cartonné pendant qu'on
fait est ce qu'on a envie de voir des
connexions comme ça aujourd'hui
franchement non je suis désolé c'est ses
potes c'est un mauvais souvenir je
trompe pas lui rendre service
alors que l'émission est super m6 avait
une super idée en faisant cette émission
pendant le continent il avait battu tout
le monde en audience à risque y est
numéro 1
et là c'est vrai que là la connexion
comme ça et tout c'est pas le sait qu'on
n'est pas dans ce délire et je pense que
c'est pourquoi il invite pas le mec à
côté venus en fait dans le studio je
pense que ce serait mieux donc comme ce
qu'elle fait norbert wii ou bien même
patrick un mec un pote c'est un pote à
moi parce que j'adore suez lignac qui a
su et je pense que c'est un gros gros
talons et voilà et cesser ses galères de
voir les mecs comme ça avec une mauvaise
position un problème qui les patins
l'aller sera utile et gnocchis toulouse
on va c'est une thématique pas de vous
un vrai problème est que tout le monde
se pose la question
cyril c'est quoi votre style de femme
c'est pas mon des liens ces travaux
derrière voilà bon chacun ses goûts
d'ailleurs vous allez voir cette année
dans l'émission du couple parfait à une
candidate qui a des goûts un peu
spéciaux force ils dorment atypique déjà
activement jamais mais en plus moi qui
serai quand moi comme une enquête en
étroite collaboration avec le fbi on a
réussi à retrouver l'ex de cette tournée
date en question métier mais comment tu
fais pour mes tes tongs
[Applaudissements]
doit on la doit pas sortir avec mick et
nathan de la main dans la main avec
mitterrand zone interdite a consacré un
numéro spécial aux vacances en camping
car ça a cartonné à lagrasse dit ça va
être à nous ça va être des tentes et
finalement pas pour tout le monde parce
que vous avez déjà six et vous de faire
un créneau en camping-car assembé asenga
les regarde le truc qui serait bien
c'est qu'on se bat en brèche tu vois
caméra dans un sens pour qu'on ait les
deux porte en face à face à face
encore faut-il se comprendre pourquoi
ils n'avancent pas de naître
[Musique]
je
regardez le bien ce gars il vous dit
rien pourtant il n'en est pas à sa
première télé rappelez-vous 2016
discours de macron le gars était
traducteur pour les malentendants
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est exceptionnel jorion j'ai presque
envie de le revoir mais parce qu'on peut
on peut on peut aller sur 17 pour voir
la tête et est allé badji clause non
mais c'est pas lui le revoilà la
championne qui serait bien c'est qu'on
se mette tête bêche
tu vois on tient vraiment de sens pour
qu'on ait les deux porte en face à face
à face encore faut-il se comprendre
pourquoi il avance pas de m
[Musique]
qui
c'est bien là les nerfs va j'espère site
baptisé j'adore en voir une toile et on
termine avec le talent du joueur termine
comme tous les soirs avec le talent du
jeune talent du jour c'est une
championne du monde et c'est une vraie
championne avec un vrai sport qui
déchaîne les passions
le décorticage de crevettes quotas lors
de jours
il a beaucoup de talent ça va être très
dur parce que le podium est dessinée là
bas ça revient fort et revient fort je
pensais être juste
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
quelle veine droit mais je crois
qu'après avoir vu ça on peut mourir
tranquille
[Applaudissements]